The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Welcome.
This is great.
It almost looks like the
beginning of the Fall, at
least outside.
So, what we are going to do,
is it's going to be a very
exciting month.
And mainly the reason for doing
this course, is I think
we are about a software
crisis.
So there's an interesting quote
I want to start with.
This is somebody very famous in
computer science, who spoke
during his student
award lecture.
His point was, when the
computers were small, there's
no problem.
When computers got bigger,
this is basically when
software started having
problems.
So, the first software crisis,
in fact, happened around the
'60s and '70s.
The problem for the first
software crisis was people are
writing Assembly language
program.
When the computers are small,
and memory was small, it was
completely doable.
No problem.
But as computers became larger
and larger, it became very
hard to write Assembly language
programs. And what
they needed was some kind of
abstraction portability.
So you should be able to go
every two years, to not have
to rewrite the programs
in there.
So you need portability and
you need some level of
abstraction.
So, what that means is instead
of writing all Assembly
hacking and dealing with every
hardware feature, you can
erase about that.
And the way that we solved it,
in that generation is, we,
came up with these high level
languages like Fortran and C.
And what those did was, they
kind of provided a common
machine language across
these machines.
And so what these did was, they
looked at all machines
those days, the uniprocessors,
and kind of abstracted out:
First of all, all the common
properties made available for
the programmer.
So it didn't really lead the
programmer too far away from
the machine.
But it abstracted out
all the differences.
So by doing that, we avoided,
we managed to get these
languagese like C and Fortran.
Weren't very fast.
Pretty efficient.
And working through this.
So that's how we avoided the
first software crisis.
And I think that a lot of really
good work happened, and
a few people got Turing
Awards for doing
these kind of things.
And then, we faced a second
software crisis in
the '80s and '90s.
The problem there was, C was
great if two guys sit in a
corner and write a program.
When Microsoft started
programming Word, Word suite,
with a few hundred programmers,
the problem was
the bugs never went away.
The project was supposed
to finish in a year.
It lasted three years.
And bugs kept coming
and coming.
And they had no idea when the
project was going to finish.
Because the way you write in a
small piece of code really
didn't scale.
And, this was a huge crisis for
people, who said we will
never be able write large
programs. Because these
programs will never work.
They're going to be brittle.
And the problem there is we
want to be able to build
software that's composable,
malleable, and maintainable.
So software should be: Multiple
people should
be able to do it.
Compose it.
And the requirements say it
should be easy to change and
easy to maintain.
The interesting thing is, we
never cared about high
performance at that time.
Moore's law.
They started to take
care of that.
The way we solved
that crisis --
Again, a lot of people got very
famous for doing that, is
came up with things like
object-oriented programming languages.
C#, C++, and now C# and Java,
basically made it possible
for, now, hundreds if not
thousands of people to develop
programs. If you look at
something like new Microsoft
products coming out, thousands
of people are involved.
And still they manage to
get it out on time.
And, also we did a bunch
of better tools.
Things like component
libraries,
and tools like Purify.
And we developed a lot of
software engineering
methodology to develop
software.
We made it more of a process
than an ad hoc art-form.
This is great.
So here we are today.
We are very happy.
A lot of programmers, yes.
Unfortunately, programmers are
pretty oblivious to what's
happening in hardware.
We don't care.
Programs don't have to know
about what things are running.
You have these nice
virtual machines.
And, of course, Moore's law,
this great new thing is going
to come and take
care of all us.
If you want speed, just
wait six months, the
machines will be faster.
And that's the thing we
have been going on.
The nice thing is, these
programs, programs written
even in the '70s, still run.
Probably two, three, orders of
magnitude faster, because
processors today have gotten
really fast. And this
abstraction gave us huge
amounts of power.
Just say, don't care
what's underneath.
We are going to sit up there,
and just basically program.
We were very happy with that.
The problem is, we are running
into an issue here.
So, we are at the beginning of
this third software crisis.
What I call the software
crisis due to
the multicore menace.
So, multicore, for hardware
people, it's a good
opportunity.
But for software people, its
kind of a menace in there.
Problem is, sequential programs
are left behind by
Moore's law.
And, as you see, as probably a
lot of you know, that you're
not going to get performance
on sequential programs,
increased performance, without
dealing with this
And -- the key thing here is,
so why don't we just stop?
OK.
Good.
We have the programs. Machines
today run very fast. Isn't
that good enough?
The problem is, we
want it all.
We need to support
new features.
We need to support things like
large datasets in the same
programs. And we kind of keep
expecting a certain
performance gain every year.
To sustain portability and
malleability, we assume that
every few years, the machines'
performance will double.
Because we believe in that.
For example, Microsoft Word at
the beginning, ten years ago,
it still works.
But it didn't have Spellcheck
running in the background.
We didn't deal with
very large images.
We didn't deal with XML
formats in there.
And, then of course, next
generation, we probably want
to have integrated video, audio,
voice recognition, all
those things in there.
And, we need that power.
We rely on that power.
And this is going to be a big
problem, because sequential
programs are stuck.
They're not going to provide
that power anymore.
And it's critical.
This kind of power is critical
to keep up the
current rate of evolution.
And, if we get stuck there,
we are going to have
a big crisis happening.
So, how is this happening?
I talked about Moore's law.
So this the obligatory
slide of Moore's law.
So if you look at it, going from
even before the 1970's,
we had this amazing, amazing
growth in the number of
transistors available.
So Moore's law doesn't say
anything about performance.
It says about the number
of transistors
available on a die.
Every 18 months, it doubles.
So, this basically -- some
people even say -- this is the
basis of these last two decades
of economic expansion.
Because we got all this amazing
power, because of this
kind of growth in here.
The problem is, if you
look at performance,
it's flattening out.
So, this is spec numbers.
Kind of the way you measure
performance is to have this
set of programs that
we can keep
running on these machines.
And we keep running on
these same machines.
So even though we are getting
twice the amount of
transistors, this is kind
of flattening out.
And then, for the last few
years, it's almost constant.
We're not getting anything
from there.
And so, we're still running from
the fumes of that amazing
growth rates we had
in this time.
And now we're kind of flattening
out in here.
And why is this?
The main reason for this is, I
will talk about four things.
One
is power consumption.
Wire delay, and DRAM access
time, and diminishing returns.
So I'll go a little bit into
these details, to kind of give
you an overview of why
this happened.
The first thing is power.
So as we go about, we keep
taking more and more power.
Right now, if you look at the
one Moore trend, that,
normally, these one point-some
volts that these processors
run, this draws more
current than any of
your houses back home.
I mean, that's amazing.
The houses probably draw
like 150 amps.
And in one volt, we are drawing
about 150 watts.
So there's that much current
going to those things.
And, heat is a big issue.
So this still shows, OK, power,
we are flattening out.
But another interesting thing
is power efficiency.
So, we are trying to use
these transistors.
We are trying to do more and
more out of these transistors.
And if you look at how many
watts, you are spending to get
one of those spec rates, that's
basically how much to
do the same amount of work, we
are spending a lot more power.
Because we are building these
things that have very marginal
return today.
That is the problem in
building the current
super-scaled type things.
Because it doesn't go.
This power efficiency.
This is why Google is building
their shops next to the Grand
Coulee dam, because they are
sucking in so much power.
Because power efficiency is
a big issue for them.
And, today, microprocessors,
most the cost of it is more
than purchasing.
It's basically feeding it with
power and cooling it.
So another problem
is wire delay.
If you try to build this
monolithic, large process.
So what happened is, in the
good old days, within the
clock cycle, in the processor
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] this side.
You can basically send a wire
from one end to another
processor, still within
one clock cycle.
So if you are building this
monolithic thing, it's almost
like sitting in a room.
When I talk, the other end
of the room will hear it
instantaneously.
Because I'm talking slowly,
or you're clocking slowly.
And today, we are around this
area, So what that means is,
in a clock cycle, you can't
get a wire for more than a
small part of the chip.
So it's almost like trying to
communicate in this building.
I want to tell something to
everybody, I can't broadcast.
Somebody has to go next-door
to tell somebody to get the
information through
the entire thing.
Takes time.
And as we go more and more, this
is going to be harder and
harder and harder.
And what that means is, trying
to build large, monolithic,
processors like we did to keep
the Moore's law kind of
performance going,
is not working.
And we have this problem.
Interesting third issue
is DRAM access time.
So what's happening is
microprocessors going like this.
Performance gets faster
and faster.
DRAM gets doubled only
about every 10 years.
And because of that, there's
this interesting mismatch.
If you are trying to get to
DRAM, if you put things in
DRAM, it's almost -- about 10
years ago the kind of latency
we had to the disk, is now
we are having to DRAM.
So the way we look at this
activity, the costs of it are
going to get big.
And it's also a power issue
because if you're on chip,
it's probably two orders of
magnitude cheaper to get to a
word on chip then go all the way
outside, get to the DRAM
and get things out.
And so, between power and this,
is also creating a huge
amount of issue, an
impossibility for us to keep
this kind of Moore's law type
performance to keep going.
The final thing is diminishing
returns.
So if you look at the `80s,
that is the era of
superscalars.
We had amazing performance
improvements.
For example, when you started
the decade, every CPI speed,
clocks per instructions.
How many clocks you had to run
to get one instruction going?
At the beginning of the decade,
you had to have about
10 clock cycles to execute
one instruction on
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
At the end of the decade, we
went about one clock cycle
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
we get a new instruction
graduated from that.
And that gave an amazing
performance boost.
And in the '90s, we had an era
of diminishing returns.
We kind of went from this
two-way, superscaled, almost
like six-way out of order, out
of issue, branch prediction,
everything's predicated.
And this huge pipeline.
Amazingly complex machines.
But we went from one clock per
instruction to about half a
clock per instruction.
So we just doubled that
kind of performance.
And performance was below
expectations, and projects got
delayed and cancelled.
One thing that failed --
I'm not going to talk
about that much.
Is, even at this time, you could
get that clock frequency
higher and higher.
And because of power and other
physical limitations, we are
also hitting a wall in
clock frequency.
We are not getting -- because at
that time, if you realize,
everybody [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
saying how fast
their machine ran.
And they have stopped that,
because they can't get
machines to double their
frequencies any more.
So, between those two, your
performance kind of stuck.
So that is why now we are
starting the new era of
multicores.
We need explicit parallelism.
We can't build these large
monolithic things that keep
giving you performance
every few years.
That stopped.
And we can build a sequential
machine where what you get in
10 years' time will almost be
same as what you get today.
But, we get more and
more silicon.
It's doubling.
Moore's law still keeps going.
So what you do with that silicon
is replicate, and
build more.
And that's where we are going.
So, if you look at what's
happening, the unicores are a
dying breed.
The last big one was Intel had
this project that tried to
build very fast, amazing,
superscalar machines.
All those projects had
to get cancelled.
Because they could not
get the performance.
Power was way too high,
they couldn't get
the power in there.
And those things
got cancelled.
And as you see, there's
more and more
multicores coming in there.
In fact, if you look at
it, multicores are
here in a big way.
If you look all these machines,
the Pentium line of
uniprocessors.
From recent time, there had been
four cores, eight cores
and even machines that have
more than 256 cores.
Small cores, but we are
basically going into -- that's
a new trend.
And if you look at the trend
line, it's an interesting
trend line going in there.
So, what I'm going to do
now is switch gears.
Because, we had Mike [? Brown ?]
from IBM.
We are very fortunate to have
him here to give us a feel
about the cell processor.
Because we are going to spend
this month really getting to
understand cell processing.
And really taking advantage
of that.
And he had done huge amounts
of work with cells.
He's at IBM TJ Watson.
And so he's going to, in the
next hour, hour and half, he's
going to give us the
lowdown on cell.
And then I will conclude with
a little bit more remarks
about how we are going to
do the class structure.
OK.
Mike.
Hopefully -- he has to catch a
flight, so we will kind of go
fast. Hopefully you guys
[INAUDIBLE] go without too
much of a break.
So if things get too tired, let
us know so we'll see if we
can put a break in the middle.